foreign
Christina you know I live on the
internet I'm working on my phone
addiction this year it's one of my
resolutions but because of that I get to
see all the great videos on social media
before anyone else and usually they make
me angry and they rile me up but I
stumbled across one that made me laugh
and brought me a little bit of Joy it's
a little bit dark but I think you're
going to enjoy it can we play it let's
do it all right roll that clip
I have thousands of dollars in gambling
debt
that you would all probably call student
loans
[Laughter]
but I like to look at that as me betting
on myself
and losing
[Applause]
uh brilliant a brilliant comedian just
perfect timing and delivery in such a
beautifully dark analogy about student
loans I couldn't decide whether to laugh
or cringe well you're a better person
than me I immediately laughed that's
just straight up and it's coming from a
comedian so clearly she doesn't take
herself too seriously
think about this but then I was like oh
the student loan companies are like the
Vegas casinos and they're inviting you
in with open arms saying you can win big
and she's saying I'm betting on myself
and the funny thing is The House Always
Wins don't they the student loan
companies always win
it's just so sad and also also uh
I'm allowed to laugh at that right yes
gosh Christina live a little live laugh
persevere we all know how the saying
goes It's funny but it's also so true so
it brings me to my next Point there's
this uh article from Yahoo here's the
headline get this meet the 30 year old
with a hundred and ten thousand dollars
in student debt who chose her jobs in
hopes of Public service loan forgiveness
but her balance just keeps growing like
a fungus this uh this woman Kirsten Lane
she's 30 years old and she had
undergraduate graduate degrees went into
a career in the non-profit sector in
theory to get the Forgiveness which in
reality didn't quite work out the
elusive forgiveness and she says I never
miss a payment always on time and yet my
balances never go down I don't
understand how people can't see that
there's something wrong with this
picture and here's the crazy part she
obviously I guess found out this program
is riddled with flaws the public student
loan forgiveness program so she paused
that strategy for that 10-year program
to take a marketing agency job in the
private sector with a salary that brings
her much closer to the 90 grand the
federal government estimated she would
need to afford to pay back the debt
goodness gracious well and it's
interesting too because she said she
went to her dream School counting on
forgiveness so basically like that
little carrot that was dangled of
forgiveness actually affected which
school she chose and what career she
chose right but she actually went to a
more expensive school because she was
counting on that forgiveness and we were
like who why does it matter they're
going to forgive it no matter the cost
oh until they don't until they don't
well and that's what's kind of
obviously man this gets me fired up but
it's like this is what is so scary about
this conversation about forgiveness and
all of these students who are going to
school who are looking to go to college
is that now going to make them pick more
expensive schools because they think
someday they're going to get their loans
forgiveness or it's going to be capped
there's income based repayment so I
might as well borrow 300 000 because I'm
only going to pay five percent of my
salary if you're out to dinner and a
generous person is like hey guys I'm
covering the dinner get whatever you
want you're not getting the cheapest
thing on the menu right you're going to
get an appetizer you're going to get the
steak maybe some dessert maybe a
cocktail and that's kind of how it is
with these student loans in the
forgiveness program they're just going
I'm going to go to whatever my dream
school is whatever the cost is and the
Monopoly money well that's for someone
else to worry about
and it just doesn't pan out like that in
reality and no one makes the money they
thought they would make Because by the
way to get the Forgiveness you've got to
be in the public sector which by the way
pays less on average than the private
sector and so you get stuck in these
rhythms and she calls it a catch-22 in
the article and she goes on to say I was
paying 300 bucks until the pandemic hit
and I think for three or four years my
balances never went down they always
went up
well and that that alone is a bit
problematic because with a hundred and
ten thousand dollar balance paying 300 a
month with a balance going up that means
you're just paying interest you're not
really tackling the prince it must mean
the interest is high enough and the
payment is low enough that you're not
making any progress on that balance and
I you know when I hosted The Borrowed
future podcast series we did I talked to
Terry who had fifteen thousand dollars
of student loan debt that ballooned up
to 60. decades later
as life hit her and she struggled and
she was suicidal it was so sad talking
to her and hearing her heart going I was
worth more dead than I was alive
that is that is sad and so many people
feel this way when it comes to student
loans they're going I was told that this
was going to be the best thing for me
the guidance counselors the student loan
companies the marketing it's all saying
we're investing in your future
and uh like that comedian said I bet on
myself and I lost that's what it feels
like when it comes to student loans well
and that's that's kind of the way they
sell it too is it's like it's good debt
it's good debt it's how you advance it's
necessary everybody's doing it it's not
and this it's just not this quote from
her in the article sums it up the
hardest thing is that I trusted in the
system that I was told from a very young
age was going to be my path to
Prosperity or a decent not exorbitant
but a decent middle class life where I
could give back to the community that
helped raise me and supported me and
that that's and she said it feels like a
big broken promise now and that
describes the entire uh college system
student loan system that we find
ourselves in today and we covered this
in depth in the borrowed future
documentary which is now free on YouTube
and Christina you were featured in that
kind of showing the other side of saying
hey you don't have to go down this path
you can go to college debt free it's
possible and it's possible I want over
half a million dollars in scholarships
my mom gave me a challenge my freshman
year of high school basically said
you're on your own paying for college
but at the same time I expect you to go
to college and you know expect you she's
an immigrant from Venezuela and so she
was like I worked to get this far now
you got to take the Baton further so how
are you going to get scholarships how
are you going to go to school debt free
and that really encouraged me to start
hustling you know I did a ton of
volunteer work in high school I did a
ton of extracurricular activities and
then I treated the scholarship
application process like a part-time job
my Junior and Senior year and so it is
possible you know but you got to take
student loan debt off the table we have
to you know get it through to students
that that's not the way when you're when
there's no debt on the table when that
is not an option you're gonna get
creative and find ways and it's so
interesting people have talked to me and
they're like Christina you must have
been anti-det you know when you were in
high school but at the time honestly I
didn't even know that like I could get
student loans thankfully thankfully my
mom being from Venezuela was a benefit
for us they handled debt a bit
differently there so I didn't realize
that I could take out student loans I
thought if I didn't have enough cash to
pay for college if I didn't find a way
to pay for it that I couldn't go to
school so that really motivated me to
figure out how to win scholarships and
to get myself out there you know but
taking debt off the table it just really
encourages you to be strategic and to
figure out different ways and you know
something else I'm pretty concerned
about over the next year that I think
people need to be really mindful of is
there's a lot of changes happening right
now with public student loan forgiveness
and this program has already it's misled
a lot of people over the last several
years I think it was like two percent of
people who who applied for the program
actually got their debt forgiveness
um there's there's been some waivers
recently they're saying there's some
full things going into effect in June
it's all still TBD there's a lot kind of
out there so I think it's just important
to encourage students to still go to
school debt free I mean this is all it's
all the Forgiveness stuff right it's it
sounds it sounds so beautiful it sounds
so attractive but then you have stories
like Kirsten's where she's a hundred and
ten thousand dollars in debt still
waiting to see if it's going to happen
and just getting frustrated so y'all you
are the solution to your problems you
can go to school debt free you can be
strategic you can win scholarships you
can go to a tuition assistance program
you can go to a community college there
are so many ways to get educated that do
not involve debt so take it off the
table there is hope to be found and it's
in the mirror it's not in the federal
government it's not in the next bill
it's not at the White House you're not
going to find it there it's right there
in the mirror and this is the year you
can start to make progress on that debt
become debt free and we want to show you
how to do that I got out of thirty six
thousand dollars of student loan debt
and you can to America you can do this
but it takes deciding that your hope is
not going to be found anywhere else but
that mirror you got this